è
accaduto anche qua vogliono farci ha
coperto e
così sta fermo dal cinema off il parkour
roadster la super divertente presto
abbiamo presto presto comunque vediamo
cosa succede ecco il chino macchinose
[Musica]
dinosauri oceano
non vedo l'ora che inizi il film sui
dinosauri league ora andiamo a prendere
i biglietti prima che inizi il film ok
ok
ecco io vitale siamo dobbiamo trovare il
modo di arrivare a prendere i biglietti
wow quanta gente è così e gigante questo
cinema salirà su queste lattina di coca
cola e non cade
e non so come fate a volte si store
accellera vitale se non avete avrei
lasciato un mi piace lasciate un mi
piace a me con la fila per i biglietti 6
e sino a prendere i biglietti solo qui
ti sto aspettando
pop corn e per me è come dire qui fila
aiutarti noi vorranno dei biglietti dei
biglietti per favore e ci sono anch'io
tre biglietti ecco tieni il film inizia
fra treni tre minuti
anche morlino la minore firmerò
dobbiamo attraversare il corridoio e non
dobbiamo cercare di prima mano per lardo
presto attraverso il corridoio abbiamo
vediamo dopo pure io mi sono sfracellato
abbiamo traversare il corridoio prima si
annega tempo attento tampone caramelle
fragiello vai piano gli occhiali 3d
avete mai visto un film in 3d al sito
megatron ei commenti io ho visto
solamente avatar mentre leggo e tu io ho
visto io ho visto un film in 3d ma non
mi
portavo pensando a mangiare figurarmi
riportato dal film quando andiamo al
cinema è quello che prendi pop corn e
taglia xxxxl più gradi della sua faccia
fd mangia lui ho una domanda come ha
fatto sorpassare belle dai sbrigati
avanti ecco come si fa ok quante volte
si sfracella era vitale per i commenti
già più tre perché negli occhiali
allora aspettatemi valutando ci sei mi
sono corti ma la scaletta sono caduto
sul pos corner quando ecco quello è il
posto in cui dobbiamo sederci e adesso
c'è sempre la pubblicità all'inizio
quindi
femminista fra dieci secondi prima di
ferragosto ha così bloccato
ok io mi sono seduta è stata è vitale
solo con il ritorno ai brigatisti e di d
amico per non disturbare gli altri ma il
piano era qui vai inizio ha iniziato il
film è un vulcano
sta per succedere qualcosa secondo me
che è successo è caduto
il suo estro ora di guardare dove un
film
rho blocks assieme a voi più di un'ora
eccolo o no no
stop di rosaura
sotto lo schermo ma ma non c'era uno
schermo nel cinema cittadino d'oro notte
a scappare un dinosauro sono mangiato di
losanna va beh siamo stati mangiati dal
di rotta voi non è bellissima questo
schifo come è possibile dice boh non lo
so moriremo qua
calmati steve c'è sempre un modo per
uscire da quel modo lì che lo facciamo
bene ora che i denti affilati questo
siamo pronti e sceglie arriverà dalla
gola del dinosauro
scaduto
facciamo temporali di a salvare non so
come aiuto l'ho venduto piano piano le
ma forse vista un sogno saltare in
corrispondenza delle costole
ma dove disegno saltare forse solo nelle
costole il signore che carino
mancato poco
ecco cosa ha mangiato il dinosauro cosa
mangiano
voi fate parte della storia family per
entrare a far parte dell'atto rispoli v
bat a iscrivervi al canale la soia un
baby piace qua e se fate parte della
stories feminine non potete non aver più
mio nuovissimo libro storie paurose a
scuola di misteri per i primissimi che
preordinano riceverete la cartolina
autografata da me è vitale è una storia
bellissima che vi appassionerà i del
terrà incollati alle pagine non
riuscirete a smettere di leggere anche
se non vi piace leggere vi terrà
incollati alle pagine se volete saperne
di più cliccate nel link in descrizione
potete preordinarla sua mazza allora che
cosa ha mangiato il chi lo sa e ci sono
delle mosche può mangiare umano molto
bene c'è anche un teschio a provvedere
puro non dinosauro che si mantiene in
forma manca pure le mele o no non ti
voglio dire da no io resto qui c'è gente
molto brutta
non avevamo mai visto da teca che tutti
i gradi e rob lowe questa
rete ha mostrato il nostro la cacca
pronto il programma votato
dai dai dai costava facile se vediamo o
no come hai fatto ad arrivare qui non lo
so stavamo guardando un film non importa
dobbiamo scappare prima che il dinosauro
ritorni ok quindi siamo in un'altra
dimensione via capiamo che cosa sono
queste cose delle banane
non è che però che sei andato io da qui
hai sbagliato
che bello dove stiamo in una giungla si
uccidono gli elefanti torino
sul portierino che tutti i profumi
sembrati pochi hanno jones
è arrivato io sono tantissimo ei
vogliamo capitale cavola lei conclude
non puo essere mercato dei cambi
senonchè avantissimo andiamo dove stessa
super velocità su per procedere in via
cimino
che preso non basta
buffon
aveva deciso di quasi decisa quasi gira
più a destra quando venite ammesso
adesso dinosauro si cappotta
si è capottato per un pelo e quello che
cos'è un portale forse ci porta al mondo
reale ha già testato risulterà prima
data assorbito presto vai attraverso il
portale così usciamo da questa giungla
pavia
ci siamo più tornati al cinema room
bellissima si è col proiettore di darci
la sana e allora dove finiremo in un
altro film abbiamo giù dalle scale non
lo so io ancora sto aspettando qualcosa
da mangiare per forza davvero pazzo se
anche tutto il cinema è pazzo dobbiamo
dire agli altri ecco il manager del
cinema così veloce non fanno in modo che
tutti quanti e sappia il mio segreto
il suo segreto è vuole vuole prendersi
meglio chiamare quindi è tutto un piano
dell'aeroporto al cinema
hai capito che bisogna stare sempre in
corso per che esplodono il manager del
cinema fa comunque dicevo il manager del
cinema organizzatori queste cose anche i
filmati armeti rincorrono tie dye con
riquadri andiamo al prossimo film
salta salta brava santoro ok ci aspetta
un altro film un altro firmati sì perché
ce l'ha spinto dovrà finire avventure
nella ceramica c'è la polizia
hanno preso fi eccoli cosa no è il
manager che arrivato la polizia studi
c'è la chiamata per noi sono questi
quelli che cercavano di rovinare il mio
cinema non ci credo ma noi siamo i buoni
che cattivi o no che cosa facciamo di
nato qui c'è un portale presto stagione
per tale ma non è giusto e lui che
dovete adesso che abbiamo in un portale
sono spesso siamo sott'acqua
come facciamo a respirare qui è in
effetti un po strano queste sono un film
possibile ok ok ciao ragazzi chi è
questo da dove venite eccoci allora fa
la del cinema avete bisogno dell'area
per respirare qua sotto non ti
preoccupare
stiamo bene sto cercando di passare
sopra questo disgustoso bacino acido
questo e dove scaricano tutti i rifiuti
tossici è la spazzatura quindi noi
dobbiamo passare da qua senza neanche a
respirare nell'aria attento a non
toccare quella cosa avverte che cos'è un
polipo questo
wow sui bari l'acidità 6 barilli
radioattivi dei gracchi
attento
io adoro le states room in cui si cambia
la mia paesaggio dicevo bastano
pelosissimi questi granchi questo mira a
gridare aiuto
anch'io sono passato presto da questa
parte
dobbiamo saltare sui der sui delfini per
arrivare alla prossima piattaforma o ok
amore stradini bisogna stare attenti a
quel
il nostro lato è andata vicino ad ora
portiamo meglio come si fa a saltare il
tempo qui guarda si stesse trasportando
morisco ok dove sei finito dall'altro
le bolle dell'uovo figo dai poi facciano
avvitare non la passa più mi piace far
portare fortuna invitare tutte è caduto
non c'è parte come al solito ed evitare
brusa ce l'ha o non vedo nessun portale
che si porterà al mondo reale e ne
rimaniamo qui allora ho trovato un
portale che ci porterà al prossimo film
il prossimo film e in egitto e il signor
sub non stai venendo con noi no come
pete andare senza di me ok va bene
pronti via
prossimo 6
wow siamo in egitto e trovi dice il
faraone o no prendetevi e forse non
dovevamo venire qua amico potevamo
rimanere giu sott'acqua
e ora che facciamo
abbiamo gli strumenti draghi c'è di
tutto lista de the meadows brigati e
questo delle mummie
lo ha detto no a questo punto corrono
così stati bravi quelle ski promo molto
facili ma invece i fratelli di continuo
io
ma come si paga e concentrazione di
no
ecco vitale si straccerà no sm l'ultima
l'ultima passato
ok cardia lui amori sono delle rane qui
perché questo guardia al questo palazzo
in area resto è ristretta non possiamo
entrare o no presi saltiamo a saperlo
stagno vanno via che carini quelle già
nell'occhio e basta come venose perché è
che sono le volte del errani possono
essere velenose c'è un tipo di rame
veleno
vista che altri tesi questo qui da bene
anche qua vogliono farsi o coperto
ho trovato il sistema per passare con
facilità e se basta andare è bravo
piaccia o no un soldato sta dicendo
prendetevi
un altro cartello e presto parliamone
l'altro portale dove si e trasporterà
passione
che ci riportano al mondo reale questa
vediamo noi siamo ritornati al cinema
della polizia ma le sembra cinema si
adesso che succede
siamo tornati indietro nel tempo guarda
c'è la freccia 4
puntiamo forse riusciamo a scappare
all'esito
si prova a dare la strada giusta è quasi
allagato
dobbiamo fare a restare per sfracellato
enel e.on o 6 sono riuscito a passare ho
trovato almeno aggiornato
o no nuovamente
vi abbiamo preso siete circondati
arrendetevi non avete nessuna parte in
cui andare cioè non potete andare da
nessuna parte arrendetevi ora però
presto scappa viso scappiamo di no
succede qua
non si fa e che cosa dobbiamo fare e
bisogna camminare qui sulla parte del
freddo ma dove stiamo in un frigo
brigata veti o no
aiuto
dai sbrighiamocì siamo quasi anche
questo è allagato tutto e cominciare
dalla giunta
chissà che numero siamo distrugge la
mente verso il corato milano ho perso il
conto di quante volte risorse dai siamo
quasi fuori dalle steve room
ok ce l'ho fatta da esiste quasi
perché
per evitare dai presto vi ama e tornato
all'inizio entrare lì nel vento per
vedere se ci porta all'uscita al sistema
della versione abbiamo presto sarà un
labirinto lo stesso potere allora perché
non mi perdo forse trovato non so bene
qua
siamo siamo usciti alle carte di queste
cellule e bigliettini e di caccia
dell'acqua di questa una festa forte la
cassa questa carta forte la nostra unica
opzione per che cosa forse per scappare
ho perduto
la cassaforte è bloccata forse la chiave
potrebbe da qualche parte presto ci
abbiate la chiave è questa disse place
messe un po dice abbiamo rubato presto
prima avevo l'età wow
dove stiamo
aspettando
ci sono invasore no tav
che ha scoraggiato sentito
povero il laser che mi aspettava adesso
ho capito che potevo diventare milionari
con questo tesoro
io sto ancora fermo al primo laser non
distrarti non abbiamo tempo quindi non
sono scoregge il laser che fa a
piegarsi su questa scala così forse
arriviamo nel soffitto nel detto proprio
il soffitto
sono bloccato su cui sulla scala brividi
ma capolino
o no
ci siamo buttati si mostra dell'ati che
è successo
il manager cia in seguito ci ha fatto
buttare giù dall'edificio
non so se siamo morti
risvegliati ben 8 mm è finito abbiamo
mangiato pesante abbiamo sognato tutto
ti sei fermentato durante tutto il film
da bravi il film era bellissimo non ci
credo non sappiamo che cosa dire per
fortuna era solo un sogno anche perché
se non saremo sfracellati s
niente stiamo finalmente fuori dal
cinema ha finalmente vediamo la luce ho
un'idea persone una gara l'ultimo che
arriva è un nuovo marzo
dove
già disastro celata dai
sulle macchine
ancora non mi sono sfollate incredibile
devo prendere e belgio prima di tutto
sì è
[Musica]
vero che appesta correndo velocissimo
lui come è possibile che i bottoni
sono altri portali lì per fare altri
giochi allora innanzitutto frega un bel
tour live match del
futuro giusto anche evitare apre tre
cose sky blue carpet andate subito a
preordinare storie vol 1 scolari
vittorie ora vi lasciamo quattro casi
non puoi cliccare per vedere i nostri
altri video e capi su quella che
preferite buona visione